[Applause]
fun movie together boys on the side and
we just we were young we had fun we were
really authentic friends we were and we
had a great time of girl movies back
then
celebrating female friendship you did
fried green tomatoes which were you're
going to teach us to cook that was the
epitome
of female friendship but that movie was
that movie was perfect for you because
you were such a woman's woman and a girl
and i always felt like you want everyone
to win i do especially the females i
feel like you are always rooting for
everybody which some people put that on
and you can tell that behind that is
another face going on but you really
mean it and i love that about you and i
loved it i got to be truly who i was and
like you and would be like we were just
us we were ourselves and we loved and
embraced and had the best time i mean we
worked hard we did like it was it it her
bros our director yeah he loved you so
much matthew mcconaughey's like one of
his big breakouts yeah and he was
walking around the halls talking to
himself do you remember that a lot of
fun together mcconaughey
yeah
he would talk to himself and he oh my
god he played abe lincoln i know oh my
god i remember that herbert ross our
director was like i discovered
the next big star and we were like
yeah okay wow you see that like he was
oh he's so dynamic all right so speaking
of female friendship working together
food love and all things wonderful teach
us how to make your beautiful popcorn so
they're really simple and they're so
celebratory and so beautiful they're so
they make people really happy so the the
number one thing to remember is that
things should be at room temperature the
eggs should be at room temperature the
milk should be at room temperature you
can warm it if you want and this should
be preheated so as you're making the
batter this will pretend like ah ah it's
hot but it's not so you'd put this in
the oven at 450. this is a very unique
this is not your cupcake tin no this is
a pop-over and you put a pad of butter
in each one so the butter browns so this
is just room temp eggs room temp milk
and you mix it in with the flour and it
can be lumpy the batter can be a little
bit lumpy mm-hmm yeah just go for it and
you you also have a little bit of melted
butter
and a little bit of butter i love this
thing i can't believe it's still here
everybody every single time look at this
several spouses
also your cookware back there
gorgeous this is not our line i'm not
i'm this is we would not make this
i'm already messy but this does me no
favors okay so you have a little pinch
of salt but it's not really i like salt
because i like it when it has a savory
cake somewhere in there so do i do the
whole thing or no just like another
pinch i don't really use recipes that
much but you know you're more of an
eyeballer vanilla
a little bit of melted butter
oh do you remember you used to imitate
fabio oh my god yes she used to walk
around saying i can't believe it's not
butter yeah made me laugh every time i
don't know why yeah
how hilarious why do i remember that
amazing so this is what they're going to
be in the end rolled in the cinnamon
sugar
and
mixed with either maple cream cheese or
maple butter should i fill these
okay so fill them about three quarters
full that was going to be my next
question
perfect perfection oh god i'm so uptight
in my stomach right now just so you know
i don't have that like sexy whimsical
thing in the kitchen
so do these go into the oven i love this
on tv when they put it in i know the
magic of tv isn't that fun and then so
here this is the magic you open the oven
for me will i are you kidding me this is
the
this one yeah perfect
i'll stick it in i love a popover tin
magic oh magic
[Applause]
all good all good okay and then now that
the popovers are done browned butter
browned butter roll it roll it in the
browned butter roll in the brown butter
no problem whatsoever rolling in brown
butter
no everything's better with butter so
now cream cheese or butter
which would you prefer how about the
maple butter sure maple butter so it has
maple butter it's butter mixed with
maple syrup and then you put the maple
butter inside okay so here we go oh my
god
cheers
[Applause]
i'm going to make it now with my girls
oh and they're going to be yeah
and then now then they'll they're tanked
for like an hour afterwards they're like
super happy and then they're like that
yeah
yeah that's fine it's it's worth it
hashtag worth it
[Music]
you